in this video you're going to be getting
started with react from creating a
skeleton react app all the way to
building this reusable real world
component which is an autocomplete text
box with suggestions that filter as you
type
so what is react react is a JavaScript
library created by Facebook for building
user interfaces it allows you to build
in combined reusable UI components much
like creating your own custom HTML tags
these components are declarative views
which update as the data in your
application updates ie
they react to changes in your
applications State hence the name of the
library enough background let's get
started you need a recent version of
node for this to work so if you haven't
got that installed already go and do
that first when that's done in the
terminal I want you to type NPM install
- G create - react - app this will
install an NPM package that creates
bare-bones react apps for you with all
the web pack configuration and required
modules already set up for you so you
can start cluding straightaway
after that's done installing you need to
do create - react - app then a space and
the name of whatever you want to call
your new app let's call it my - first -
app and this will set up your new react
app and install all the necessary
dependencies that'll take a little while
and after it's done you need to go into
the directory that's just been created
that's my first app and you'll see here
it's installed an NPM application for us
it's created our bare-bones react app
and we just do an NPM start and this
will this will compile the app and run
the dev server it's also in the moment
going to open here we go it opens a
browser window and runs the app in it
for you that's very convenient so it's
still just loading it's still probably
compiling in the background
and there we go and this is the
bare-bones react app and you can see
here it tells you to go to SRC at j/s
edit the code and save and it will auto
reload so let's do that now to start off
with we're just going to fly through
building a really simple component with
react just as a taster after that we'll
move on to the autocomplete text box
which is more useful but also more
complex open the code in an editor of
your choice and go to the SRC folder and
then you want to go to app jess and this
is the main top level app component that
renders what we saw in the browser if
you remember there's this text here
about getting started let's just edit
this and change it to say hello world
and if we save it and go back to the
browser code recompiles it hot reloads
and we get hello world so now let's
create our first react components and
then we'll be able to use it just like a
custom HTML tag really we're going to
make a component which is a button and
some dynamic text when you click the
button it's going to toggle hiding a
text
so in SRC I want you to create a new
file we're going to call it hi double
text yes we're going to import react
from react then we're going to export as
default a new class and we're going to
call that hi double text and it needs to
extend the react dot component class we
give it a constructor and the
constructor takes an argument cause
called props these are just properties
for the components and they can be
passed in like attributes are passed to
an HTML tag and we do just need to call
C
in the constructor passing through the
props and super just calls the parent
class constructor so it's coloring the
reactive component constructor that just
ensures the class is set up properly
next we have a very special function
called render now whatever gets returned
from render is what gets rendered in the
browser for this component so we're
going to return some JSX it's called
which is xml within JavaScript and this
JSX is just going to be a div so it's
just like doing HTML tags within our
JavaScript early it's going to be a div
and then we're going to have a button
and we'll call it toggle and then some
just some hard-coded text for now now we
have this component we can go ahead and
import it into our app components so we
open that file and we just imported it
import hide of all text from hide of all
text now we can use it pretty much like
a custom HTML tag so if we can within
this day of class they map content we
just go hide of all text like an HTML
tag we save it and then we'll have a
look and see how it looks in the browser
and there we go we've got our button
that does nothing at the moment
and our text reacts elements can take
arguments called props that are a lot
like attributes for HTML tags so to our
hi double text we'll add one called
text and as the valley just as a string
we will put dynamic text now we go back
to our component
and that text prop will be available in
the component within an object called
this dot props it comes in via the
constructor here and is passed to the
superclass so we want to output this
here and if you want to output the
results of an expression in JSX you just
wrap the expression in curly braces
that's completely wrong wrap the
expression in curly braces so we're
going to do this dot props dot text and
that will be the dynamic text we just
passed in as the prop so if we save this
and take a look in the browser the text
should have changed so now as we can see
we've now got our dynamic text and the
button does absolutely nothing let's fix
that now props are one form of data
available to react components they are
passed in from outside the component as
we saw and are immutable but we can also
store internal mutable data within a
component and this is called state we
will define this within the constructor
so we'll go this dot state and state is
a special property on a react component
so it has to be called state and it's
just a plain or JavaScript objects so we
can just define it as an object literal
we will add and is hidden property
defaulting to false so obviously if is
hidden is true the text will be hidden
otherwise it will be shown and we can
achieve that by going down here and
doing not this dot state dot is hidden
and props dot text this means the text
will only show if is hidden is true next
we need a way to toggle is hidden so
let's go up here let's create a new
method on the class called toggle is
hidden it doesn't take any arguments and
this is going to use a special method
which is inherited from the react
component class and this is called set
state for reasons I won't go into now
because it's
beyond the scope of the video this lot
state should never be altered manually
after being initially set up in the
constructor so we call this set state
and this takes function as an argument
and it gives us actually the current
state as an argument to this function
and then this function has to return the
changes we want to make to the state
object in the form of an object so we'll
return an object and we want is hidden
to be the result of toggling the current
is hidden so current state thought is
hidden and again for reasons I won't go
into now because it's too complicated
for the moment you must always you get
the current value of any state object
when you're doing a set state from
current state not from this dot state
you'll have to watch my entire react
course to find out why I think it's a
bit more complicated but this toggle is
hidden function will do exactly what we
want
next comes the task of hooking toggle is
hidden up to this button here it's
actually very simple it's a lot like in
HTML and JavaScript without react how
you would have out how you would add
rather an event handler you just put it
straight on as an attribute on click in
this case it's going to be an expression
so we want the curly braces again and
then we just put an arrow function and
all the CEREC function is going to do is
call this the toggle is him let's save
that and check this in the browser first
I have just noticed a big error in
toggle is hidden I set the new value is
hidden to be exactly the same as the
current value which is obviously wrong
we want to negate it
so it's toggled and now it should work
so in the browser we have the toggle
button and we have the dynamic text we
click toggle and the text disappears we
toggle it again and it reappears so that
working as intended so what's happening
here is when we initially render the
button is hidden is false and so the
text is hidden and when we click the
button toggle is hidden is called set
state is called and it sets is hidden to
true each time we update the state of
react component the component re-renders
so the render function is called again
and so when we click for the first time
and is hidden is set to true this
function is then called again this time
is hidden is true and so the text isn't
shown now we're going to move on to
building a more useful real-world
component I'm going to be teaching you
how to build this autocomplete textbox
using react it's one of those text boxes
where you type and get a list of
possible items you can select which fill
in the text box a bit like the auto
suggestion search boxes on most search
engines what I really like about this is
that it has real world uses it's a very
simple component but by creating it
you'll learn about reusable react
components props component States and
using CSS with react you'll first need
to set up a new react SAP by installing
create react app creating a new app with
it and then run it by going to the
directory in the terminal and doing NPM
start alternatively you could just put
the code within the app you previously
created it's up to you open the code in
an editor we're going to create a new
component first create a new file for
your components and call it
autocompletes XJS and it should be in
the SRC folder components are the
building blocks of any Reax application
they can be configured using something
called props more on that later in the
series and they can hold their own
mutable data called state they can be
used to represent anything in your UI
from small things like a standalone UI
widget such as this autocomplete text
box we're going to create right up until
ooh something large like an INT
webpage components are reusable so you
can use them many times on one page or
even across different pages they are
also composable you can think of them
like Lego bricks you can fit them
together to build other larger
components first we need to import the
react module you need to do this for
every component you create then we
create a class to represent our
components and we're going to call it
autocompletes text it needs to extend
the react component class in order to
make it a component our textbox will
need the list of all possible items that
it can autocomplete with in a future
video I'll show you how to make that
configurable but for now we're just
going to hard code a list of names to do
this first create a constructor react
component constructors must take an
argument called props and call the
superclass constructor passing the props
argument to it this just ensures the
component is set up properly let's add a
member variable called items so it's
this two items and it's going to be an
array we create a member variable so we
can access it from anywhere in the class
later so let's add some names now to the
array these will be what can be shown in
the autocomplete drop-down they're all
the possible items to autocomplete with
now the markup for our component at the
heart of any react component is the
render function it will examine all the
components data and based on this will
render the markup for the component the
idea is that when the components data
changes the mark-up changes so the user
sees something different so we define
our render function from this we must
return the react elements we want to
represent our components some magic
called JSX
lets us write them directly within
JavaScript as HTML tax so we're going to
return a rapid eV and inside it a text
inputs this is going to be our text box
we're also going to put an unordered
list to hold our autocomplete
suggestions we'll worry about showing
only items that match the text entered
later for now let's show all the items
in the list so we have this as an array
so we can just output an Li for each
item in the items array now this is
going to be an expression and to mix
expressions into our markup using JSX we
need to wrap them in curly braces
anything within curly braces will be
evaluated and the value output within
our markup this can be anything from a
simple string to the results of a
function call or even other react
elements we want one Li per item in the
list so inside those curly braces we're
going to map over the array an output
and Li for each item within the Li we
have the item itself this itself is an
expression so is also wrapped in the
curly braces the result of this map is
an array of react elements now if we put
an array of react elements within curly
brackets each element in that array will
be rendered although we're nowhere near
finished yet I think this is a good time
to check how our new component looks in
the browser so far we have our new
component but haven't used it anywhere
we can use the component just like a
custom HTML tag the component itself is
just the definition we need a new
instance of this definition which will
be a react element let's do that now so
you want to go to app Jess this is our
main top level component for app and
we're just going to delete all this we
don't need that header section at all
and we also want to go into index dot
CSS and just put 50 pixels and margin at
the top of the body just so we've got a
bit of space up there when we put our
text box in so first we need to import
our components module and we're going to
use the components just like a custom
HTML tag
so it's just autocomplete text as an
HTML tag so you should be running the
app using NPM start in the folder in the
terminal so that it will haunt reload in
the browser when you change the code
let's take a look as you can see we have
our text box and our list with all the
names in it when the user types in the
text box we're going to need to know
about it so we can filter the list so
that only items that match what the user
types are displayed we're also going to
need the current sex which has been
entered for the same reason so let's get
that text now you can add events to
elements in react much the same way as
you can in HTML so this text input has
an unchanged event available so we add
that and we're going to assign a
function to it since a function is an
expression we wrap it in curly brackets
and all the function is going to do is
take the event that has been generated
and console dot log event dot target dot
value or a target value because is the
event target is the element which is the
target of the event and the value is the
value of the HTML text input let's check
that in the browser so we right-click
and choose inspect to open the developer
console and choose console from the tab
above then we type in the text field and
as we do you can see the text being
output each time we change the value in
order to only show items in the list
that match the text entered we need to
use the component state component state
is just internal data belonging to the
current instance of the component since
it belongs to the current instance you
can have multiple versions of the same
component on the same page at the same
time and they each keep their own
individual state so in this dot items we
have all the possible items we will
store the list of items which match what
is entered in the textbox in the
component
state the state is initialized in the
constructor it is just a plain old
JavaScript object but it must be called
state and must be on the current
instance ie on this as this is the
property react that component uses for
the state it's like a property which is
special to react so we're going to
create this dot state and it's going to
equal a new object literal for the list
of suggestions we'll have a property
called suggestions when the component is
first created we want the suggestions to
be empty so let's go ahead and make it
an empty array let's create a function
to handle the user typing in the text
box we'll call it on text changed and
it's very important that it's an arrow
function or this won't work if you don't
understand why this is you need to learn
about function context in JavaScript the
function will take the unchanged event
as an argument we'll call it a and now
let's go down to the unchanged attribute
in the tax box and we're going to add
that function there we just put this dot
on text change
there's no brackets at the end we're not
calling the function just assigning it
so we need to get the value from the
event if the string is empty we're going
to want to make sure that the
suggestions are empty as there's nothing
to match on this case would happen for
example if the user types a single
character and then deletes it
now you might think we empty the
suggestions array by doing something
like this dot state dot suggestions
equals empty array that seems to make
sense doesn't it we just set the
suggestions array on the state to be
empty however this would be the wrong
way to update a value in the state the
reason for this is that what gets
rendered in the render function will
probably depend upon the state now in
this case it doesn't yet but we'll be
making render do this in just a minute
the idea is when you change the state
you change what gets rendered so that
the component displays something
different this is what makes react
components dynamic rather than static
for this reason the component needs to
know that the state has changed so it
can re render call render again and
display the new version of the component
to the user react component gives us a
function is called set state that does
just this so it's this dot set state and
now this takes a function which will
return an object with any state changes
in it so any properties we want to
change in the state go in that object
the reason it takes a function that
returns an object instead of just an
object is beyond the scope of this video
I do however talk about this in my udemy
course so we want to set the suggestions
to empty rate so the function just
returns an object with suggestions as an
empty array you don't need to return the
entire state from this function just the
properties you want to change the else
case is if for the text isn't empty for
this case we're going to create a case
insensitive reg X to test for matches in
the items list that start with the text
the user entered
next we're going to define the list of
max matching suggestions and put it in a
Const and this is going to be defined as
taking the contents of the items array
sorting it alphabetically and filtering
it for items that match the Reg X we
just created
we then need to update the state with
the filtered list of suggestions and
actually I've just thought of a better
way of writing this so we're going to
use let's and define suggestions so it's
mutable and we're going to initialize it
as an empty array and if the length of
the string entered is more than 0 we set
suggestions to be the filtered list of
items so we just need the Reg X in there
and then the filtered suggestions in
there as well
and then after that we just set
suggestions in the state this does
exactly the same thing it's just more
concise now we're only going to render
the filtered list of suggestions instead
of the full list I'm going to create a
function to do this which I'm going to
call render suggestions so we D
structure the suggestions from the state
and if this list is empty we don't want
to show the UL element at all and to do
this we can just return null from this
function anything that is null won't
render anything to the browser so next
is if it's not empty and in this case we
want to copy and paste all the code from
down here from the render function or
cut and paste rather for the UL so we're
going to return that and within that
instead of mapping over the items array
which is sort of all the items that we
have because we only want to output the
suggestions we change it to suggestions
instead of items then in the render
function we call render suggestions in
the place of where we had the mark up
for our URL so now what should happen is
when I type in the text box only items
which match the value entered gets shown
but we have an error via test is not a
function it actually says there's two
errors on the page but they're both the
same let's just go and fix this now so
I've got things the wrong way around
here I've done text value test instead
of reg X test and I need to pass in the
text value to the test function so just
the wrong way around there you go back
try again cannot read property map of
undefined again just a small bug it's
not this suggestions dot map it's just
suggestions as we've already
destructured third time's a charm we're
now getting everything filtered as I
type what's happening is the suggestions
are being updated in the state as I type
each time they are the components render
function gets called again and it only
returns the list with the matching items
as this is what's in the state at the
time the font
is called so we have our filtered list
next we need to make it so when we click
an item on the list it populates the
text box with it to do this we need to
be in control of the value of the text
input now there are two types of
controls in reacts or inputs rather
controlled and uncontrolled currently
this textbox is uncontrolled this means
the browser controls the value the user
types and the text appears in the
textbox if we make our textbox
controlled we control the value via
react we make it controlled simply by
adding a value prop and we'll set this
now to an empty string so look what
happens when we're in control of the
textbox fire react I am actually now
typing in the text box and nothing will
appear we will have to set the value
ourselves from within the component you
will set the value of the text box using
the component state to do this we're
going to add a text property to the
state and the value should just be an
empty string then we want to go down to
our render function and we want to
extract this text value from the state
and then in our text box we're going to
make that Valley prop the text from the
state so that's what goes in the text
box now we go to the on text change
function and when the textbox value
changes we want to set that value in the
state as text now when we type in the
text box the value updates to select the
item we need a function to say a
suggestion has been selected so we're
going to go ahead and add a function
suggestion selected it's going to take
the value of the suggestion which will
be one of the items from the suggestion
list as an argument we're then going to
update the state so
the value the textbox uses is the
selected suggestion at this point we're
also going to wipe the suggestions list
by sent setting it to be an empty array
as we don't want to still share it when
the user has just selected an item
finally we need this to fire when a
suggestion is clicked on so we're going
to go down to the Ally for a suggestion
item and we're going to add an on click
event handler and we're going to add an
arrow function in there and this is
going to call this dot suggestion
selected with the suggestion text for
this Ally we should now be done and
everything should work now as we type it
filters the list and when we make our
selection it populates the text box so
that's a success there are a number of
ways to handle CSS in react today I'm
going to show you the simplest you see
here we have our app dot CSS file this
came with create react app and then if
we go into our components our app
components JavaScript file we import it
just like we would a JavaScript module
not forgetting to add the dot CSS
extension this parts very important now
looking in the browser and viewing the
source we go into the head section and
we scroll down a bit and there's this
style tag here and within it we see the
contents of app CSS what's happening
here is that create react app has set up
a web pack loader phorus web pack is a
commonly used JavaScript build tool
anyway this loader is intercepting
imports of files based on the dot CSS
extension it is then adding code to add
a style tag into the web page using
javascript and putting the contents of
all the imported CSS
in here that's what happened with app
dot CSS so let's add our own CSS file so
we had a new file for our CSS
autocomplete text dot CSS within that
we're going to add a class autocomplete
text for now we're just going to put a
width of 100% on it next we go to our
component and we need to import
autocomplete text dot CSS remember the
dot CSS extension this now ensures that
the CSS we wrote shows up in the head of
the document just like without dot CSS
we can now apply the class we added to a
react element so we're going to apply it
to the wrapper div now one thing to note
this is very important in JSX
you can't just use the class attribute
because it's a reserved word in
JavaScript so you can't put just that
instead we have to use class name
uppercase on then but this acts just
like the class attribute in HTML so we
add our auto complete text class in
there let's check that in the browser so
we can go to the head and we can see the
style has been added they're looking at
the finished product we can work out
what we need to do in terms of styling
firstly let's take the width since this
is a reusable component we want a
flexible width I think the best way to
achieve this is to make everything 100%
width then when someone uses the
component they can put in a fixed width
container in order to dictate the final
width of the component now let's look at
the border so we have a gray border with
a drop shadow my first thought was to
put a border around both the text input
and the UL that appears with the
suggestions the main problem of this is
that if we put a border and drop shadow
on both elements they would overlap
at the bottom of the text input and the
top of the UL the simplest solution is
just that the container div has a border
and a drop shadow while the UL and text
have none
this way when just the text box is shown
the border wraps that when the
suggestion list is also shown it wraps
both components so let's make those
changes now the width of our container
is already a hundred percent so let's
add a new selector for the text input
and give that a width of 100% to we then
add a gray border to our container and
then we want to drop shadow on it too so
we add some code from that now I just
generated this with an online tool you
can Google CSS box shadow generator and
you'll find a similar tool and we take
off the border from the input so we're
going to go into our app component now
and we're going to wrap the text box in
a div with the class name of app -
component then we go back to app dot CSS
and we do a selector for app - component
as a class and we're going to put some
margin on the top of it because we just
want a spit of space between the top of
the browser and the component and in the
margin of the slides is going to be Auto
to Center it's and we give it a width of
600 pixels this is to constrain the size
of our reusable component from outside
of the component so once we finish that
we'll save and have a look in the
browser taking a look at this we see
that the text in the list is centered we
want it left aligned also you want to
get rid of those bullet points let's do
that now
so I'm just going to give the entire div
and also the input a consistent text
style so they just look the same I'm now
going to put in a new selector for the
UL and with list-style-type set to 9 I
get rid of the bullets and I align the
text to the left if we have a look at
our elements we can see the alignment is
a bit off between the text input in the
list and there's this funny thing going
on with the right-hand side of the text
box there's a couple of things going on
here we need to use border box box
sizing on it otherwise the text input
can end up being more than a hundred
percent width of its parent but if the
text input and the list items should
also have consistent padding finally
there's also a small you probably can't
see it but there is a small gap between
the top of the UL and the bottom of the
text input the throws thing is off just
a little bit this is caused by the new
line between the two in the markup this
can be fixed by using the before pseudo
selector first we'll take away all the
margin and padding on the Euro elements
we won't be needing that then we're
going to add a consistent margin and
padding to both the Li and text input so
we add a new selective PL I put the
padding in there and then put the same
padding on the text input and we need to
also add to that box sizing and set it
to border box for the text input so it
doesn't get more than 100% in width
finally we're going to add a pseudo
selector for our UL this is the before
pseudo selector we're going to use and
it just allows us to remove the white
space before the UL so we're going to
send the content to be an empty string I
also want to remove this blue
highlighting when the text box is in
focus this is very simple to do we just
add outline:none
to the text input things are looking
really pretty good now we actually do
want to border at the top of the UL
though just to separate it from the text
input we also want to make the list of
items look clickable we can do this by
adding a cursor style and some hover
styling to the UI's so we add a border
to the top of the UL that's of course
one pixel solid gray and we set cursor
to pointer on the LI so that the cursor
has a little hand on hover so it looks
like a link something we can click then
we're going to add a new selector and
we're going to use the hover pseudo
selector on the li selector and then on
hovered we're going to give all the
Allies a background just sort of a light
gray background and an underline to
emphasise this to the user just to
emphasize that they're selectable so
yeah that all looks really good I want
some good data for our suggestions so
I'll get a list of all the countries in
the world I google for it and there's
actually a text file for it on github
which is perfect so I click view raw and
I copy all of them you want the
countries to be an array so I create a
new module country zas in SRC and we
simply paste in the entire list and
we're going to export it from the module
as the default export I'm going to wrap
it in backticks so it can be multi-line
as opposed to say single or double
quotes and make sure there's no space at
the beginning or the end of the
backticks
and then I do a dot split on the newline
character and this will make it an array
one line or country in this case per
item the module now exports an array of
country names so if we go to our
component we have an array called this
dot items which contains the hard-coded
items names in this case we need to
transfer
this into a prop props in react are a
way to get data into a component in
order to make it configurable you pass
props to a react element just like an
HTML attribute so if we have a look at
the text input down here we use two
props on that one is value one is
unchanged so this is just how you get
props into a react element and you can
see up here the props are passed to the
constructor we then pass them to super
and after that they can be accessed
foreign object this dot props from
anywhere in the class
so we remove this dot items from the
constructor we don't need it anymore and
we use this variable in the function on
text change where we filtered these
items to get the suggestions based on
what the user typed so let's do
structure this dot props to get a prop
called items and then we use that in
place of this dot items now we need to
go to the app component where we
actually use the text box and past in
the countries as a prop called items so
first we need to import our countries
from the countries module we created
then we add items as a prop just like an
attribute and give it the value of
countries in curly braces so now the
text box has our list of countries
available but what happens if we wanted
to add another text box with different
items on the same page we simply add
another autocomplete text tag this one
will set the items to be an array of
names we'll just hard code the array
straight in the curly brackets straight
into the prop items
we now have to autocomplete text boxes
there are a bit squished together so
let's just add a bit of space in here so
now we've got to autocomplete text boxes
on one page each has its own internal
state both has its own list of items so
we've created a truly reusable component
if you want to progress to building
entire apps in react instead of just
components see the link to my course
learn react and redux from beginner to
paid professional in the video
description